y'all of course what's missing in that
introduction is the the coincidence that
up to astrophysicists in a row and
standing in front of you so so my talk
is primarily about the streaming data
analytics we will want to do on the
night of things and of course we heard
some some really good tools this morning
already when Steven talk to us some of
the sort of the computational things you
want to do on data but to get there you
have to have computable data which is
what we hear a lot about when we come to
these conferences which I which is a
very important aspect of the data
science that we do which is taking these
streams which might be unstructured data
and might be video might be it might be
text it might be social media it might
be anything and turning it into
something that we can compute on and so
the Assumption in the talk today is is
that what you've done something already
to prepare your data for computable
algorithm or algorithms to work on it in
a computable fashion and so the so the
application systems I'll be numerous
mentioned here I'll give three use cases
and two of the use cases will be
metaphors and you'll understand what i
mean when i get to those metaphors and
that is one will be an astronomy example
one will be a planetary science example
and they and the point of those examples
is not that I'm teaching astronomy or
anything like that it's these are
metaphors for the dynamic streaming data
that you may encounter and whatever
applications you're working in so we
live in this world where more and more
things are becoming connected we call
this the Internet of Things and this
Internet of Things is not is not just a
network of things connected through
these network protocols but also that
there's actually streaming data between
these things ok so we're collecting data
from people processes objects events all
of which are creating data for which
from which we can make discoveries and
take decisions and then improve our
processes in our businesses whether its
financial services or health care or
whatever so the so the broad world of
internet of things that sometimes now
called the internet of everything okay
so the internet of everything is listed
here which you can't even read the
details here but it includes things like
transportation and housing and industry
and healthcare and IT networks in
and the energy grid and so on so we're
facing numerous challenges in this this
new world in which we have so many
things connected in so many things
generating data so I take advantage of a
sort of the historical language around
big data where we have the 3 v's of big
data which of course we don't want to
hear about when we come here but but but
I talk about the three ease of Internet
of Things specifically just just to
highlight challenges that this Internet
of Things is going to bring to us and
that is first of all everywhere a sensor
that is everywhere you turn there's a
sense of whether whether it's your
health wearable device your SmartWatch
or your Fitbit or something like that or
or the the items in your home have a
little wifis or or a personal area
network so what we call pi phi so you
have this personal internet of
information exchange between devices in
your home or your local environment and
so we'll have a sensor essentially on
everything and in doing so that for
we're quantifying and tracking life and
processes and things both in space and
time so it's an enabling a world of
discovery but also that discovery has
this the sort of the negative aspect
which is this 30 which is the erosion of
privacy okay so maybe you don't want
people to know where you're going or
what you're looking at or what you're
shopping for and things like that so so
there's a lot of discussion that can be
had around that aspect of it that's not
the discussion specifically today today
is much more focused on the sort of the
science side of this of what kind of
discovery can we make what kind of
application algorithms can we apply to
that and so the challenges from the data
perspective are these three we call them
the 3 b's of big data but i want to i
want to focus specifically what i call
the deep white and fast data okay so by
deep meaning we have since the sensors
are tracking so many different kinds of
things we're getting a deep view of
whatever the thing you're tracking
whether it's your customers how they
behave online whether it's processes in
your manufacturing plant machines on
them on an airline of like the engines
on the airline or already kind of supply
chain it's the movement of your products
so we have sensors on everything and
we're getting this deep view of how our
process or our business or the system is
operating
so we have this deep data we also have
wide data by wide we mean this in the
context of high variety that is it's
very complex data it's a video its
images its sound it's text its documents
it could be data tables or it could not
be well we have many different data
types in the coming at us in many
different ways so this diversity and
complexity of the data is an enormous
challenge of how do you fuse and make
decisions off of this a mixture of
different types of data and then fast
referring to the fact that it were
basically sampling at maybe a completely
different rate for each device but we're
sampling in time all of these data so we
don't just measure something once and
walk away so you might say sort of
traditional demographics for example
credit scoring when you go to the bank
and decide whether to give you a student
loan or not they may look at this or
your age your gender what kind of
college education you're working toward
of things that nowadays we would just
say that's not really a very smart way
to make a decision but there's based
upon static data okay things that don't
change okay so now that as we heard this
morning about the real-time bidding on
ad placement really great talking I hope
you saw that this morning I mean these
are sort of micro second decisions or
you know very fast decisions based upon
a mechana such decisions made every
second throughout every single day so so
dealing with this time series data is
and yet another aspect of the Internet
of Things challenge so you really can't
just have a back-up plan all right so so
if you're doing credit scoring on your
customers for example in a financial
institution your backup plan might be
you'll you'll get some data off of
public sites okay so you'll find some
public information about your customer
whether they whether or not they should
receive this particular loan or credit
or or whatever in the casement and I
think the whole point in anything is
that your dynamically monitoring
something whether it's your health or
cyber security environment or
manufacturing on the plant for or an
engine on an airplane that you happen to
be flying at this moment you don't want
to know that that engine passed its test
five years ago you want to know now is
this thing operate
efficiently and properly so all this
there's really no backup plan so fast
data you really have to have sort of
fast analytics that are very smart to
deal with the data that you don't have
so fortunately we have all these
challenges but there's also a great
benefit from all this and I and again to
keep it sort of the play on words here
but again the play on words is just
basically a mnemonic way of remembering
these things so I call it the 3d to DS
ok data to discovery data to decisions
and data to dollars or data to dividends
however you want to call it ok so the
real benefits of doing these things with
data as we all know which is why we're
here we already know this ok but we're
going to see this even amplified in the
Internet of Things world is that the
ability to make new discoveries make
better decisions and then to create new
business value new innovation is just
being amplified as well as the data
itself so there's many use cases that I
want to read this slide to you as an eye
chart but there's many examples whether
it's in health care retail or marketing
or smart cities or smart highways or
smart education or precision medicine
and industrial Internet of Things where
you have these sensors on the
manufacturing plant floor or is it in
your supply chain or wherever all of
these different use case examples come
down to sort of what I call the three or
the XYZ excuse me of IOT and the XYZ is
that it's smart something or precision
something or personalized something okay
smart cities smart highways personalized
education personalized medicine
personalized marketing targeted
marketing okay precision medicine
precision farming okay precision
wine-growing did you miss that on the
previous slide so precision wine growing
okay talking about the specific care and
feeding and nurturing and planting
seasons and specific plots of land where
you plant certain siege and how you
handle that okay so all this data is now
being collected everywhere let's make
the best use of it that's sort of the
general idea and so the real business
value the real business benefit that
come in it's going to come out of this
it's sort of this very precision way of
making decisions precision way of doing
delivery to customers into clients or to
your business application areas that's
what's being enabled here
so wheel out so we live in the
interconnected dynamic world okay so
from this vast universe of possibilities
like I said I'm going to give you a few
examples so the big challenge that comes
out of this of course is doing the
streaming data analytics so that's that
sort of the message here and I just want
to give you a couple examples of this
before we move into the metaphors
because then when I'm talking about
astronomy and planetary science you're
going to say what were we talking about
again yeah and some so these streaming
data analytics examples might be
something as simple as I say a simple
because it's sort of in your back door
in your back door or in your backyard
that you find already and that is web
analytics okay so traditional web
analytics is a lot of times it's sort of
hindsight okay sort of what happened
okay business reporting tells me what
happened last month okay so many site
visitors so many people clicked on this
so many people clicked on that but but
but all of data analytics now it is is
sort of moving beyond that descriptive
analytics phase two more predictive
analytics that is what will happen based
upon the patterns I see too prescriptive
analytics which is how can I achieve the
best possible outcome not just the
predicted outcome and so in marketing
for example so in marketing we see how
people in digital marketing we see how
on site visitors are moving through your
web property for example if you have an
online store you want to see what
they're looking at and maybe make
recommendations of products to buy if
you're running a federal agency the site
visitors might be citizens or it might
be other agencies who are looking at
your reports the data you're providing
whatever sort of policy decisions you're
making people are looking at things on
your site and you want to say well gee
they seem to be interested in this maybe
we should recommend they look at this
report or this document or this data set
okay so this whole sort of dynamic way
of interacting with your customers and
your clients is changing and that's just
one example of this type of behavior
which we're familiar with all the time
but now we're seeing this advance into
all these other use cases so these use
cases may include health alerts okay so
real-time discovery so we heard about
Google Flu Trends before in the past or
based upon people searches for flu
symptoms and Google Google was able to
predict it ahead of the Centers for
Disease Control the outbreak of clue and
of course there's been all kinds of
stories about how that didn't quite work
because sometimes people did that search
just because they were interested in and
learning about something about flu they
heard in the news there now they're
doing a search it doesn't mean they have
the flu but now with electronic health
records we have a group sort of almost
almost real-time sort of ability to
capture symptoms and diagnosis and
treatments that that have to do with
particular types of diseases and so this
is creating now a data stream that can
be mined now maybe maybe not mind by you
and me about by healthcare professionals
at the national international institutes
of health or Centers for Disease Control
or wherever so electronic health record
monitoring to generate health alerts
maybe even tsunami alerts if you're
talking about sort of geophysical signal
processing and signal alerting cyber
security alerts obviously we want to be
careful about about those that is when
we start seeing people tending toward
doing something bad that's not wait till
they do something bad let's stop it
before it happens a social event mining
people talk about social listening quite
a bit social listening is applicable and
a lot of settings but not just sentiment
analysis that people really like that
coca-cola commercial during the Super
Bowl I mean that's fine for coca-cola
they want to know the answer to that
question but most of the rest of us
don't really care that much what social
listening might have more to do about
what's the sentiment of the Baltimore
today okay so there's the first sort of
a rain witnessed discussions today about
those six police officers who were being
arraigned on the then the death of that
person okay so that's in the news today
okay there's all kinds of stuff
happening in baltimore today and so you
maybe want to get the sense or the mood
of the population all right so that kind
of thing is important for a lot of
different reasons preventive bottled
fraud alerts certainly in any kind of
financial transaction whether it's a
commercial banking or financial services
or maybe in a federal agency that's
doing payment disbursement for example
Medicare payments Veterans
Administration payments whatever can you
capture the fraud the attempted fraud
before it happens predictive maintenance
alerts from machines infrastructure
monitoring from your bigoted sensors
everywhere so this these are all
sort of general statements of things
that we want to try to do in many
different application areas but it sort
of comes under this umbrella of risk
mitigation I would say so the real
business equation we're trying to
balance here is the risk versus reward
okay so how do we achieve the reward
given all the risks that we faced with
the erosion data privacy but also the
risk of if we don't monitor these things
if we don't have good analytics we're
going to miss some big event we're going
to miss the tsunami we're going to miss
the outbreak of flu we're going to miss
the cyber security intrusion on our
network how do we sort of balance that
so so this is what I call these 3d td's
which is this whole aspect of what are
we using this data for anyways what's
the point I mean I often given this talk
to people who in the early days when I
we first started talking about big data
a lot of times people would just react
to the word big data said oh this is
just nonsense okay but yeah there was a
lot of hype around big data and a lot of
it probably was nonsense okay but people
sort of missed the real key point there
which is we're using this data to do
something to make discoveries to make
better decisions to improve the value of
our processes the about improve increase
value and innovation within our
organizations so this is really what
we're trying to achieve here so from the
machine learning and data science
perspective i'd like to see at least
these sort of four sort of applications
machine learning applications somewhere
in your iot pipeline somewhere in your
data analytics pipeline for that
streaming data that is can you discover
behaviors okay can you discover when
something is different okay so this is
class discovery okay so class discovery
sometimes it's called clustering or
unsupervised learning or segmentation
different words like that but it's
finding the new behaviors finding the
new things that are happening so a
colleague of mine is doing this kind of
class discovery process on something
which is not exactly internet of things
but could be construed as Internet of
Things okay so he's doing a very simple
math problem but the math probably has
an application and his application which
is not what he's doing he's doing the
math problem the application is
identifying individuals and airports
through all the surveillance cameras
through
out an airport so imagine a very large
Airport lots of for surveillance cameras
probably a million passengers a day go
through there and and identifying the
past each passenger at each location in
time where they are in the airport
during that day okay so that requires
facial recognition software and all
kinds of stuff like that and then you
got to do connect the dots that is this
person when here that person went there
okay so there's a lot of things going on
there once you've connected those dots
you now have trajectories okay so you
may have a million passengers I mean you
have a million trajectories of people
moving through your Airport each day and
most of those trajectories are very
similar okay so class discovery there's
a certain class of behave cusp of claw
Airport passengers they go through
security they go sit at their gate and
they stay there to the plane departs
then there's another class of people who
go find their gate then they go to
Starbucks and get a coffee then they go
back to their gate and then oh by the
way I had too much coffee I gotta go to
the restroom then I go back to my gate
so there's so there's a there's another
pattern of behavior so imagine if you
found a pattern which is a customer air
passenger is walking back and forth
between the domestic terminal and the
international terminal that's not normal
in fact not too many people do that
maybe the security people do that but
not normal airline passenger okay so
that's discovering a new kind of
behavior a new class of behavior so so
class discovery is of that type it's not
just you know classes and in some kind
of three-dimensional plot and say oh
these points are clustered over here
that's a new class it's it can be in a
graph space it can be in a video space
it can be in a time series trajectory
space or whatever so class describing
something you should be looking for
finding new things new emergent
behaviors so in cybersecurity world they
talk about the zero-day virus right that
that is the thing that that it doesn't
exist until today and by the time you
know that it exists they've already
stolen your data okay so there is there
is no model McAfee doesn't have that in
their model right because they haven't
seen that one before and now they put it
in their model tomorrow oh it's too late
because that your data is gone today
okay so can you identify those new
behaviors those new classes right away
so class discovery next one is
correlation discovery okay so
correlation discovery I like to put
under
under the moniker predictive power
discovery so what a correlation does
hopefully if it's not a spurious
correlation which this gentleman you can
tell it up kind of high get that
argument so the spurious correlation is
a problem when you're trying to identify
whether there's a causation or sort of
explanatory factor there but beyond that
if if you do see a correlation in your
data besides understand understand why
it's there that correlation can now be
used in a predictive fashion okay so
you're discovering the ability to
predict the future when you see a
correlation so when you see a correlates
with B and then you see a change a
certain way that you can expect me to
change a certain way so finding these
patterns and trends and behaviors in
their data is yet another thing we want
to get out of our streaming data to
identify those transit correlations and
then be able to make a prediction okay
because that prediction may again may
indicate that an engine failure on an
airplane or a plant machine failure on
the manufacturing floor okay so you want
to find those trends okay find those
correlations so that you can get the
signals early and respond accordingly so
the correlations those patterns when I
say sort of represent the DNA of
whatever system you're monitoring ok so
the DNA when your DNA all right you have
a certain sequence and you which witch
predetermines you know what color hair
you can have a color eyes you're going
to have when you start losing your hair
what age it will turn gray there's all
kinds of things that are defined about
you in your DNA ok so these trends and
correlations whether there's causal
factors or whatever those those trends
of correlations represent sort of a
model of the system you're monitoring so
understanding that DNA and it enables
you to better understand not only your
system but when something starts going
in a direction that needs to be
monitored or corrected so number three
on this less Association discovery so
the Association discover you about you
might traditionally want to call like
market basket analysis all right so that
that sort it puts your mind a business
use case but I want to necessarily put
it in a business use case it's finding
things that tend to co-occur together
that you wouldn't expect ok so these
co-occurring two associations also can
become very predictive ok finding these
associate
is important again for making the best
use of your IOT data so again think of
data discovered that you might discover
some new Association dated the decisions
that as you see one thing for example if
you want to build a recommender engine
on recommending products or ad placement
like we heard this morning okay so you
see that people who liked this also
liked that people who shop here also
want to buy that people who have these
preferences tend to walk by this thing
so you can find these associations and
make good business use case out of it
but it's not just for a business use
case I had a colleague of mine who's
applying this technique to predicting
the the intensification of hurricanes so
he's able to look at data when the
hurricane is still far out in the
Atlantic Ocean the sea surface
temperature the the sheer speed across
the the hurricane wall the atmospheric
pressure the temperature all kind all
kinds of different factors precipitation
and so on to predict much more
accurately than the National Hurricane
Center what the final intensity of the
hurricane will be when it makes landfall
so I don't know why they don't do this
but they're his algorithm is better than
the National Hurricane Center and it's
all done on market basket analysis by
finding co-occurring associations that
correspond with an intensity 5 hurricane
or an intensity for hurricane or so
there's lots of things you can do with
this beyond just selling products on
Amazon like recommender engine and for
me the big fund the exciting part of all
of this is the novelty discovery finding
the thing you didn't expect fighting
that needle in the haystack whether it's
an exoplanet around a distant star or
something else finding the surprising
unexpected things so so some people call
that outlier detection to me that's just
such a pejorative term up my students
and I we just call it surprise discovery
because it's a data point that's in an
unexpected place in your data set and
it's not traditional statistical
outliers like a three sigma deviation
from occur because imagine if you have
all your data on a sphere all right so
for example what's the locations of all
the people on earth okay so if you have
you had a database with the locations of
all the people on earth you would
discover that they all live within a few
miles of the surface the main surface of
the earth there are very few people who
live very far from that mean surface all
right so so now let's say you have
another data point whose XYZ so if your
coordinate system is XYZ knots
Oracle coordinates and the X Y Z values
are 0 0 & 0 okay so that person there x
me there x value is exactly is equal to
exactly the mean of the x value of every
person on earth there are y coordinate
is exactly at the mean of every person
on earth and there's eval you is exactly
at the main of every person on earth so
therefore they are not a statistical
outlier right wrong I mean they are
definitely at a very weird place in the
center of the core of the earth okay so
so outlier in this case in that sense
doesn't make too much sense which is why
we prefer to call it a surprise
discovery okay that it is in an
interesting unexpected place so all
these things become discoveries for you
when and whatever application domain
your work and it might be I get again a
novel thing or it might actually be an
anomaly okay so it's something that's
not working properly okay so pay
attention to all of these okay so
learning from our data is one of the key
reasons we collect the data you don't
collect it to stick it in the box okay
okay so anyone seen the movie raiders of
the lost ark they find the ark and then
they lock it up in a box and they nail
it shut and they put it in a warehouse
and close the door alright and I suppose
there's some index number written on the
outside okay so that index number
represents that thing alright so in some
database and some government spreadsheet
somewhere in the world of Indiana Jones
there's an entry for a wood crate with
an index number but what does that index
number do it it just tells you about
where it is it gives you no clue as to
the intrinsic discovery potential and
value of what's in that box okay so
focus on what's it what's the intrinsic
value and discover a potential of your
data more than anything else moving
forward there we go so consider these
three case studies from the universe of
possibilities that face just in this in
this realm okay so all these things are
examples what i would call dynamic data
driven application system dynamic data
driven application systems the first one
is an astronomy example as promised so
think of this again as a meta
for for a case you have it's not
unnecessarily in astronomy I exercise
your astronomy lesson as it is a
data-driven application system example
so this is a true story about a
telescope which will satisfy the first
of these 3d 2 d's that i mentioned
earlier data to discovery so here is a
telescope that's being built hello there
so this telescope is being built in
south america right now received
construction funding last year so is in
the President's budget in 2014 and
several of us including myself been
working on this for over 10 years the
project scientist who and conceded this
had been working on it for over 20 years
and so this telescope is being built in
South America it's too big to launch in
space so it is not a spaceborne
telescope it's going to do about a
complete study monitoring of the sky
repeatedly night after night after night
after night after night after night for
10 years we call a cosmic cinematography
it's just basically to take a picture of
this guy repeatedly from esting from
South America every night for 10 years
and it's going to be this movie of the
nice guy and we're going to find
everything that has changed in
brightness or moved or something somehow
has done something dynamically from
night tonight over this ten-year window
so the the image archive of this thing
is going to be in the other end the 200
petabyte range we're actually going to
create an extracted catalog a database
of all the objects and then this
different parameters to over 200
parameters size shape color position
brightness and so on in the that
database which will be an SQL query able
database is going to be about 40
petabytes okay it's going to live on
30,000 separate servers but could look
like one single SQL variable database to
you the end user so this is where the
thing will live down in Chile and
there's some astronomy use cases there
we don't need to read those specifically
it's going to take several years to
build before it becomes operational so
this telescope has a 3 gigapixel camera
so you can't buy this one at walmart so
the camera is fully one third of the
cost of the construction okay over 200
million dollar camera it takes two bytes
per pixel so it's 16 gigabyte image
every 20 seconds for 10 years okay so
I'd like to remind people that the
Hubble as we already heard today is a
pinpoint on the
guy it's extremely high resolution at
that pinpoint ok so for 25 years Hubble
has been studying the sky we have
several hundred thousand images of the
sky from Hubble but this telescope in
the first 30 minutes of its operational
what ten year lifetime it'll accumulate
more data in those first 30 minutes and
Hubble has in 25 years combined big
camera big imaging capability finding
everything that has moved in the sky and
so we expect 10 million of these every
night for 10 years I'd like to tell
people there's not enough graduate
students in the world to look at this ok
yeah so what we need is something fast
some kind of fast statistical modeling
software because this is going to be a
stream of data ok and in like a lot of
other streaming analytics problems we
all face and again this is a metaphor
not necessarily your use case obviously
those things once they've happened you
can't rewind them all right so once
someone has come into your system until
stolen your data you can't rewind it oh
let's let's back up and patch that
yesterday so he doesn't steal it an hour
ago no wait that makes no sense same
thing in our astronomical use case if a
star goes boom in the night if it's a
supernova or something happens we can't
say universe timeout go back and rewind
that for me again I missed it no so so
we have to do fast analytical processing
on these millions of events every night
and oh by the way if we can't keep up
with the 10 million tonight guess what
there's 10 million more tomorrow night
and 10 million more the next night and
so on so you got to find some way and so
why is that important since important
for astronomers because we're trying to
identify all kinds of interesting things
which was the Astronomy use-case slide
that I didn't read to you so there's all
kinds of really asked interesting
astrophysics that will miss if we don't
process our data really fast so case
study number two is a little bit more
mild and mundane by comparison to what I
just described in terms of data volume
the Mars rovers so Mars rovers more
focused i would say in this case even
though it's doing discovery obviously
but the Mars rover is this is this
little device that's running around on
the surface of Mars pretty much
autonomously making decisions what to do
next so I like to think of it as a
decision engine so even though yes it's
doing discovery but it's making a
decision so
analyzes the rocks in its presence and
it says are these interesting should I
stay here they're not interesting I
should move on do I see a trend that is
when i was there yesterday and i'm here
today i see it a sudden increase in the
amount of water in the rocks or the
amount of titanium and the rocks maybe i
should continue going up this hill or
down that Valley so finding trends and
patterns and anomalies and class
discovery are all about what this little
Mars rover is doing to make the best
decision of where to go what to do next
okay so whether this is a retail
marketing example or a health monitoring
system or a site a tsunami monitoring
system or a credit risk fraud analysis
detection algorithm you're trying to
find fast trends that are an event until
you can respond to them in real time as
much as possible okay so I think of our
little Mars rover here as this
intelligent data gather gatherer mobile
data mining an autonomous decision
support system and now the actual Mars
rovers aren't doing all of these machine
learning things in reality but in my
vision of the ideal Mars rover is going
to be doing all of these cool things to
make denial good discoveries but good
decisions and so decisions like I said
might be some of these things that you
see at the bottom of the slide for
example stay here and do more do I
continue my operations the same way I've
been operating do I follow some
interesting trend do I notify someone
immediately or can I notify someone
later okay so sometimes we just call
that tree object so when you see
something interesting is it something
hit the react to immediately or can you
wait later so I like to refer to this as
with another sort of play on words here
i call this going from sensors two
sentinels descents ok so the sensors
again in our iot world of our internet
of things world the sensors are
everywhere okay sensors are collecting
data from everything ok so we're
collecting data alright so we're
monitoring data from many different
types of sensors looking again this case
Mars rover but it doesn't have to be and
in that data stream and hopefully close
to the sensor not somewhere else in a
cloud summer though you could do it that
way but if you want to have a fast
reaction time you want to have something
close to the data which is a
engine business rules are saying that
that are doing those correlation
discovery class discovery outlier
discuss discovery Association discovery
I'm finding something interesting here
what do I do now there's a decision rule
right there that set a decision rules
and machine learning application is a
Sentinel all right that's what I mean so
what is the Sentinel sintel is the guard
on the on the castle that says oh the
enemy's coming wake up everybody okay so
this person it's not their job to fight
off the enemy all right their job is to
alert everybody that the enemy is coming
ok so the Sentinel has a set of rules
that is that it that knows when should I
wake everybody up when should I not ok I
see a bright fire a bright light over
there but maybe the enemy is burning the
forest coming toward us oh wait a minute
that's the Sun rising you laugh but I
had a student actually do this once
their assignment in my astronomy class
was to plot the location where the Sun
would rise every morning to the course
of a semester and hopefully they would
discover how the seasons change the
position of the sunrise changes over the
course of three months well about two
and a half months into the semester the
student came up to me in my class and
this was the same exercise i gave year
after year after year after year to
hundreds of students this young man came
up to me he said I think I made a
mistake what I thought was the bright
light of the Sun rising was a street
lamp down the street from my dorm room I
said how can you mistake a street lamp
for the Sun anyway I think was a good
excuse for why he didn't actually do the
assignment but any but anyway alright so
the Sentinel has a set of decision rules
and then it's up to something in the
back end whether it's a person or
algorithms or something that makes sense
of all that and i'm getting a thrown off
the stage here so our sentinels were
measuring collecting data applying
decision rules that's the sentinel and
then enables us to make intelligent
decisions based off those data alright
so that the framework I want to draw
your attention to is something which has
been part of sort of the lore so to
speak and this field of DD
AAS for several years the fact is this
dynamic data driven application systems
goes back over a decade at least so you
can read about it on this website and
they have this framework which is called
the MIPS framework which is measurement
inference prediction and steering so
it's pretty much what I said from since
two sentinels sentinels sensors two
signals a sense so the MIPS is the first
is the measurement all right so you
measure something and then the middle
part I and p.m. for instant prediction
that's where all the machine learning
cool stuff happens where you infer
what's going on build a model and do a
prediction from that and then steering
the last step is you move something you
move a person or you move an add on an
online website or you or you do
something there so they're steering your
resources pick up persons processes or
things that you move into action based
upon what you learned in that process so
our big data analytics in the IOT is
moving us from sensors two sentinels to
sense-making to ultimately dollars and
cents making hopefully and so the last
application is digital marketing
analytics and I'm going to be thrown off
the stage so I'll just sort of leave
this to your imagination but this is the
big roi the big return on innovation so
we get data from many different sources
in our marketing world in our digital
marketing world ok so it's about what
what are people doing online what's the
weather what's the context is the
diversity Super Bowl this weekend so
there's context there's time there's
location as well as clickstream so
combining all that information you can
automate that that real-time sort of
marketing delivery that real-time
marketing campaign delivery this
targeted specifically uniquely to that
individual and that's sort of the sort
of the gold standard of digital
marketing is that sharp precision
personalized marketing so making the
long story short here the final slide
here is our data science includes all of
these different approaches to data
science cluster and correlation
classification outlier all these
discoveries to enable what we're hoping
to achieve from our iot big data which
is discoveries better decisions and
insights about our processes and
therefore reap the value and the
dividends that that brings to us